recommend for almost all couples you take your paychecks
put it in the joint checking account okay
don't don't do that Doctor Zoe and I'm here to tell you not to do that
this man is recommending that couples should put
their paychecks directly into the joint account first
and then the joint account like pays them a little stipend each
why is this in particular harmful towards women
I'm also having a joint account
we opened a joint account the other day for the first time um
because my partner's from the UK
we need we need to do it for the visa
but getting paid into your joint account
and then getting a stipend means that your partner is basically
mutually giving you a little bit of pocket money
and has complete oversight over you
what you spend your money on and your finances
this approach does not account for when things go wrong
this approach is designed to and is a
is a basically hoax
back to the era where women couldn't leave domestic violence
or just couldn't leave for whatever reason
because they didn't have the financial independence to do so
and your partner has complete oversight into how much money you're getting
they can track your spending more easily and financial abuse is on the rise
it's one of the newer recognised categories of abuse
but is very much uh valid and very very severe form of abuse in fact
almost all physical abuse is preceded by financial abuse
it's a part of the abuse cycle
the abuser needs to make sure that you can't get away
even in situations where the couple wanna stay together and then start abuse
I believe that you should still have complete control of your paychecks
and they should go into your account
and as a woman like this is very gendered
this issue just because
you know we've just had the 50 year anniversary of women
being able to get their own credit card
it was not that long ago that men had complete say over our lives
through our finances it's not a very far leap from okay
I get a little stipend we share all our finances except for my little stipend
two where did your money go
you should have this much left
what did you spend that on
why did you buy that experience in an abusive relationship
I was tormented for wanting to spend $5 on a pair of denim shorts
while my boyfriend at the time
sat there in the cafe where the second hand shorts were on sale
and was drinking two five dollar beverages
it's not really about the money
it's about the control five dollar shorts
I did not buy new clothes myself for over a year in that relationship
because even though he didn't have oversight into my actual accounts
he was still tryna control my spending
he did this in numerous way
I was never a big shopper and when we broke up
I went and spent $500 um at H&M that it just opened
um yeah fast fashion but anyway
I was just I felt like I've been released from financial prison
and ever since then I found that like
buying clothes and things for myself is almost this like
symbol of freedom for me um
freedom from those in trappings
do not take this advice my mother taught me a couple things and she always said
keep your own bank account